the jurogan experience
i wanted to talk to you about this is a
little bit of a deviation but it's not
really i wanted to talk to you about
theranose
because i am
[ __ ] completely obsessed with that
lady and her scam company dude did you
know that i was almost the chief medical
officer of that company
no
yeah dude so in 2006
my mckinsey office which was in palo
alto was on the same was on page mill
which was one street over from where
theranos was located so theranos at the
time was a super small company
so a good friend of mine
his father-in-law
was on the board and knew elizabeth
holmes very well he was her professor at
stanford and
the company was small at that time it's
like maybe 30 people there something
like that
and
he um said look i you know i want you
my friend
to potentially look at this company and
because they could really use a cfo and
he was in private equity at the time
really smart guy
and uh to make long story short i got
introduced to elizabeth so i went down
and had lunch with her one day did you
ever catch her talking in a real voice
you know it's so f i don't remem i met
her later and she already had the fake
voice but i can't remember that day what
her voice was like i i wish i could
remember but you know it's like 15 years
ago right i would remember if it was
weird like i don't think i don't think
it was i think it might be if you talked
like this i would say what is going on
yeah yeah have you had throat cancer i
don't i don't what are you doing i i
think she was she must have been talking
a normal voice but here's what
interested me i sat down in the office
and she pulled out a black box that was
i don't know if it was called edison at
the time or if it was the precursor to
what would become edison
diagnostics is not something i knew a
ton about but you know i spent two years
at the nih and i certainly understand
how chemical reagents work and i
understand how chemical assays work and
i know how for example an elisa works an
elisa is a type of
assay that you do to measure something
but it requires a lot of washing and
rinsing and repeating and i know that
many biomarkers that are of interest for
example something like insulin you know
if you want to measure a person's
insulin level um
you have to do these types of assays
right
so
i was saying to her you know elizabeth i
don't understand how you could put a
drop of blood in here and get anything
out that's more interesting than glucose
hemoglobin sodium and potassium the
really simple things that can work you
know that can be measured off a drop of
blood
and she kind of gave me some answer and
i said well can i see the inside of the
box and she said absolutely not and i
said well i've signed an nda you know i
had to sign an nda to get in the
building so she was like no
so
um
i just decided i wasn't interested in
the company because i couldn't get sort
of straight answers from her so i i
ended up not doing it so fast forward to
20 this was 2006. fast forward to 2015
she's now on the cover of forbes
and
um and you're like
well no no i i remember one day saying
to my wife because she was on the cover
of forbes and the company was valued a
little over nine billion dollars and i
said to my wife do you know how much we
would be worth if i had taken that job
now
and she's like how much i told her and
she's like good
god
and
i so i'm at the um vanity fair event in
san francisco this by i didn't know it
at the time this was a week before the
wall street journal article would fall
john carrio's article that was the one
that kind of unraveled all of theranos
in october of 2015. and what how did he
figure it out
how'd this one guy figure out that it
was also i haven't read his book bad
blood um but i saw the documentary so
you know that's like a poor man's
version of it but basically just
interviewing people um who were formerly
employees of the company oh so they were
being spillers yeah yeah and they were
basically like yeah this is a total scam
oh my god and so sure enough i'm at this
reception because she and she's the
speaker of the event so she's like it's
a four day conference and she's the
she's the one everyone there is there to
see so
i'm i'm sitting at a table and i'm
having a cocktail
and
she walks up and she
and i said hey elizabeth you probably
don't remember she goes no i remember
you exactly and she remembered my name
and even remembered how i had been
introduced to her i was like really
blown away we exchanged pleasantries she
gave me her card
and then a week later it all unraveled
and it's really funny i still have the
card you should frame it yeah yeah yeah
um she must have known that this [ __ ]
was hitting no she totally did yeah yeah
because the [ __ ] was hitting the fan six
months earlier
what does one do
and it's not like you can liquidate
right like you if you're worth nine
billion dollars but it's all stock and
you know the product is nonsense you
can't even get out
well it's a private company so at best
you know she could have along the way
been doing secondaries off her take but
oh so it wasn't even yeah yeah i'm
fascinated that she wouldn't let you
look into the box because i guess if you
looked into the box you would
immediately be able to be i don't know
that i would have let's i don't want to
overstate my credentials i'm not a
clinical chemist i i'm she could have
duped me i'm sure but she didn't i mean
and again we're under nda we're talking
about me joining her company as a chief
medical officer like right how are you
not gonna let me see inside this
freaking box
like what do you want how am i gonna do
my job does she have duped you though if
she's not technically
astute like she doesn't really
understand i know she could i mean look
she
presumably duped people smarter than me
right i think she duped this is what
drives me crazy i think she duped people
from the image i think they wanted to
believe they wanted to believe that
there was this female wonderkind who
left stanford at 19 years old dropped
out of school and figured out this
amazing technology and along the way
became at least until she got busted the
richest self-made woman ever
she was worth i think like her four
billion yeah crazy
crazy
and she just faked it and one of the
ways she got busted was people from
college that she went to school with
like why are you talking like that like
what's happening and then people started
hearing that that wasn't her real voice
and then people started like
rumors and murmurs
there's so many layers to that story oh
man no doubt yeah it's a fascinating one
it really is it's such an interesting
story
so for you
when all that was going down that must
have been incredibly sweet
because now you don't have to think man
i missed out on all that money yeah for
sure and i and i was also i felt a
little bit validated like okay it
there was a reason she didn't want to
show me the inside of the box right yeah
yeah
it might have been empty it literally
might have been empty there was candy in
there
it's a giant like little thing yeah dude
she got so many people she got betsy
devos for like a hundred million
and poor general mattis i didn't have
two nickels yeah to rub together when he
gets out of the military he put like a
couple hundred k in or something obscene
for him yeah
[ __ ]
crazy whenever someone comes to me like
some guy came to me with some crazy i
mean i don't know if it's real so i
don't want to talk about it like say it
specifically but if it's true
it sounds like this guy's going to
revolutionize a form of travel and so
he's telling me about this and i was
like wow and then i said to my business
manager who's with me at the time i go
don't ever forget about theranos
whenever someone tells you something
the moment someone tells me i go yeah
when it happens i believe you i'm i
don't want to be involved in any
groundbreaking [ __ ] before it actually
launch especially in some area where i'm
completely ignorant and now what am i
gonna do just start going to school try
to figure out engineering to try to
think of this guy saying something
that's actually possible and plausible
no can't do it not interested buddy
[Laughter]
so for you though
when it did come out though there had to
be like a a cool feeling of satisfaction
there had to be a little something there
were you like i mean the first person i
called was my buddy the guy who had
introduced me to her way back and i was
like dude
what are the dinner conversations like
and he's like oh dude it's not good
because his father-in-law was still in
the believing camp oh no
oh yeah they talk about him in the yeah
oh [ __ ] so it was so he got duped long
after the the the jig was up right yeah
i i again i don't know the details but i
it was
i was like man
[ __ ] it's good that we didn't do that
but watch the entire episode for free
only on spotify